These days, we're pretty constantly bombarded
with trailers, posters and other promotional
material for new releases in major, long-running
franchises but there also happen to be a few
part-twos that have managed to stay under
the radar.
From terrifying shark encounters to fascinating
murder mysteries, let's take a look at some
It's been over five years since the men in
black last saved Earth from an alien threat,
but now Sony plans on bringing the iconic
agents back to theaters.
According to Deadline, the studio has their
latest entry in the Men in Black franchise
set for release on June 14th, 2019, but don't
expect to see Will Smith or Tommy Lee Jones
returning.
Instead, the film will focus on a new cast
of characters.
As Deadline explains, the studio wants to
produce a spinoff which can reboot and expand
the franchise in the same way that Jurassic
World did a few years earlier.
This sci-fi comedy will feature Thor: Ragnarok
stars Chris Hemsworth and Tessa Thompson,
alongside returning MiB vet Emma Thompson.
Mark your calendars and try not to forget
it’s happening.
“Uh, ladies and gentleman if you would look
right here.”
Death on the Nile
While it may have received mixed reviews from
critics, 2017’s Murder on the Orient Express
killed it at the box office, earning a worldwide
total of $339 million against a production
budget of $55 million.
With that kind of cash, it makes total sense
that Hercule Poirot and his epic facial hair
will be making a return to the silver screen.
Only this time, instead of taking a train
ride across the wintry European landscape,
he'll be taking a boat ride through the deserts
of Egypt.
“Ah, mon ami, encore.”
According to Deadline, Agatha Christie fans
can expect to see Death on the Nile sailing
into theaters on December 20th, 2019.
Based on the 1973 novel, this new adventure
will follow Poirot as he tries to solve a
murder on a riverboat that's cruising down
the Nile.
It looks like Kenneth Branagh will both direct
and play the mustachioed detective, although
we don't know yet who’ll be filling out
the rest of the cast.
However, we do know that Michael Green will
be writing the screenplay.
Not only did he pen Orient Express, but he
also wrote Logan, Blade Runner 2049 and all
eight episodes of American Gods.
Talk about a safe pair of hands.
Zombieland 2
It's been almost a decade since Zombieland
staggered into theaters, earning rave reviews
and over $100 million worldwide.
Since then, the movie has only grown in popularity,
with fans positively clamouring to see Columbus,
Tallahassee, Wichita, and Little Rock back
in action.
While there's been talk of making a part two
for quite some time, the film was never able
to come to life but now, according to The
Hollywood Reporter, a sequel is finally rising
up from development hell.
Zombieland 2 is set to hit theaters in October
2019, and it's bringing pretty much everyone
from the first movie back to the big screen.
Jesse Eisenberg, Woody Harrelson, Emma Stone,
and Abigail Breslin are all returning, as
is original director Ruben Fleischer.
Paul Wernick and Rhett Reese who penned the
first film, not to mention both Deadpool movies
are also coming back.
We don't exactly know the plot yet, but THR
says our heroes will go, quote:
"...from the White House to the American heartland
as they face off against new kinds of zombies
that have evolved since the first movie, as
well as some new human survivors."
They'll also have to learn how to get along
with one another as they make a new life for
themselves in a zombie-filled, Twinkie-less
world — which is way easier said than done.
“You might wanna buckle up, you know, for
safety.
I can tell already you are gonna get on my
nerves.”
What if you were forced to relive the same
day over and over again, Groundhog Day style,
and were always killed at the end of it by
some mysterious slasher villain?
Naturally, you'd want to discover the identity
of your masked attacker and somehow break
that vicious cycle.
Written and directed by Christopher Landon
and starring Jessica Rothe as the oft-murdered
lead Tree, 2017's Happy Death Day was a surprise
hit, raking in $122 million worldwide.
And with that kind of success, you know that
poor Tree is in for another day of butchery.
According to Variety, Blumhouse and Universal
are busy working on a sequel, titled Happy
Death Day 2U.
We don't know any real plot details yet,but
returning lead Jessica Rothe told Collider
that Happy Death Day 2U will be:
"...a Back to the Future type of genre film
where the sequel joins us right from where
we left off."
We'll get to see what fresh horror awaits
our hero on February 14th, 2019.